oh my god boy oh my god oh my god I'm in
repose I'm in repose look at me I'm in
repose
oh no I help them could make a girl look
so damn sexy hello everybody my name is
Margaret Cho
no relation I am Greece's aunt if you do
not know oh it's you on Friday with my
dear dear Franklin Doris trembles it's
us explaining how much we hate st.
Patrick's Day and how corned beef looks
like my labia your result on whether
that is actually true I show clitoris a
photo not a corned beef of my labia
which explains why she's not here today
she got very ill very ill I'm on
vacation but I wanted to take this
opportunity to sneak in and introduce
this today's video yeah we'll just look
at your own face and you're like oh my
god there is a card today great did a
video with one of her little friends
Frankie grande Oh nailed it he seems
like a delightful ray of sunshine that
Frankie grande I like him very much
he's got so much energy he's like one of
those dogs that they sell in the toys
versus just flips over and over and over
and over and then when it doesn't have
room to flip it just does this in the
corner by itself without anyone giving
any attention is still just doing it
Frankie and grace get a phone call
because Frankie's phone number leaked
and then it turns into a prank call I
remember one time called or sanaya prank
called Domino's Pizza and we ended up
with four pineapple and extra cheese
pizzas
maybe we didn't prank or maybe we just
ordered pizza I'm you really Frankie
grounded this week I'm so excited about
because I feel like every time I see you
or I see you in something I learned
something else about you I went and I
saw you as judge on a BDC yeah and I had
no idea I knew a little bit but not that
your dance history is so extensive and
you you're insanely knowledgeable about
that whole world and also not about
turning your phone off I didn't know
about this is the phone that no number
leaked oh this is a fan shree answer it
let's do it oh my gosh hello hi who's
this this is Frankie hi are you calling
for any specific reason how did you get
this number
no you didn't know that it was me or you
didn't know that it was a phone number
what didn't you know who do you think
Justin Bieber okay you were just like
okay fine I'll call this number that you
gave me why not it's a number yeah
exactly well Natalie you made a new
friend today so nice to meet you Oh me I
hope so in person that's what we'll keep
texting I'll send you my address okay
great
talk to you later bye bye I don't know
someone gave it to me goes out we did my
number as like punishment I was supposed
to meet haha to get to do something but
I was on a plane okay and so therefore
we could not meet it at said time so she
was freaking out so I'm gonna tweet our
text conversations so that everyone
knows that Frank is putting me over at
the moment
and it had your number my number of the
tums who's being funny I was like I
texted you that I was coming be late
because the flight was delayed I was
gonna meet you at Disney fest we were
gonna create something right then in
there backstage and then we're gonna go
on and do it rose we don't need to
rehearse this and cinnamon twerk she was
like I told you to kick rocks and I said
I know I said thank you and she was like
that's not a good thing oh I thought
kick rocks was like go get them kid like
kick rocks means like like exactly you
have this entire fight but I didn't know
we had a fight
you thought this is being really support
and really supportive okay okay kick
rocks Frankie seems like break a leg you
and I said I thought was breakaway no
it's our thing how the two of you don't
have your own Broadway show together is
some sort of Odd Couple like blows my
mind what is in all of the years of
doing Broadway the worst audience moment
from a show really yeah okay so
Mamma Mia uh-huh was you know I joined
it in year eight huge tourist at so we
had a lot of tourists at one point in
the show I popped my head up over the
Taverna wall and we stare at what we're
supposed to stare at the center of the
orchestra I can so we pop our heads up
and we stare at the center of the
orchestra and it's really the only time
that you know you were instructed to
stare at the audience right like it was
direct breaking the fourth wall
communicating sure so there's five of us
and I pop my head up and the entire
center of the orchestra is all wearing
medical mass say it was all white
medical masks the whole center of the
audience and I lost my [ __ ] must have
been a bus of Asian tourists who all
where medical masks because they do it's
just part of their culture absolutely
yeah it was so hysterical I mean none of
a single word ya know they slept but
that's also part of their culture they
sleep like during the show uh-huh that's
a sign of like respect like you're doing
look out in the audience
finale and there would be some people
dancing and there would be a half so
weird for another moment me a moment
it's really fun is we had this scene in
lay all your love where we were dancing
and our flippers were rubberized like
your feet you're sure yeah we can't
dancing and flip like scuba flip oh wow
so we're coming out and one day we go
off knowings and there are new flippers
and there have plastic we all go to take
our first step in all of us wipe out
because the plastic doesn't grip the
plastic stage we come flying and all of
us here dog screaming we were like well
the show must go on
so we crawled to a spot on stage like a
baby deer on ice for the first exactly
I'm supposed to push the boat off stage
and I just slip out and I'm just
dangling from the front of the ship and
then the guy the stagehand us to come on
pull the boat and drag me off see that's
one of my favorite moments that's
amazing those are the moments where I
wish the audience is allowed to use
their phones and like video capture that
so it could live online absolutely I
still think that we need to start
letting people videotape I mean I don't
think that in in shows because that was
the one kind of interesting thing about
singing Broadway shows I'm so used to
being so connected yeah and not being
able to use the phone and really feeling
like it was an offense if I used it
during the show I was like oh this is
kind of nice that this is preserved here
I agree and I think it depends on the
show like Rock of Ages why not [ __ ]
they're serving alcohol in the theater
screaming at the stage trying to crawl
up on stage it's like why not take out
your cell phone you are provoking like a
bunch of caged tigers because it's
mostly like middle-aged women that used
to love like Whitesnake we would shout
that yeah I can rock of ages' like
someone would shout something would be
like yeah we know the show was nice
because it seemed like it had that like
comfort zone you know there shows up
someone from the audience for - owl it
would be such a weird taboo moment but
it felt like appropriate ish in that
yeah I was like yeah get up damn he
wasted crawling see hopefully you guys
enjoyed that episode of not too deep
listen to the full podcast if you want
to and go to a library if you really
want to expand your minds goodbye with
you my video game B it's called Frankie
Grande's red carpet adventure jumping on
the heads of celebrities you have to get
Jennifer Aniston child